good evening thank you very much for
coming it's always a somewhat artificial
situation of two people who know each
other well and husband and wife I
suppose fall into that category to do an
interview in public like this why should
I ask her questions that I can ask her
over the breakfast table on the other
hand and one doesn't really normally
discuss Japanese naval strategy in 1941
over the breakfast table so it's as good
an opportunity as any to discuss this a
little bit further and one of the things
that I find most interesting about the
book and revealing and possibly for many
readers in this country also is that it
tackles certain myths about Pearl Harbor
and one of the myths is which was of
course very much encouraged in the
immediate post-war period not only by
the Japanese themselves but also by the
American and occupy administration is
that Japan had been hijacked by the
militarists by the military and the
civilians really were not to blame for
what happened it was a kind of
militarist coup and the Japanese people
and the Emperor himself were rarely sort
of duped by the militarists
into embarking on this reckless
adventure what would you say to that
particular myth it was a very easy and
convenient myth because it disengaged
quite a few of the people who are
actually responsible in reality and of
course for the Japanese nation as well
to think that the war could have been
averted was too painful
a question to to ask I think and that
was sort of a self-perpetuating myth
that the Japanese themselves took very
easily to after the war after having
lost so much but
in your book you also described why it's
wrong to think of it in terms of the
civilians being duped because some of
the civilian politicians not least the
Prime Minister for much of the time
Prince
Cournoyer for the model was actually to
a large extent responsible for what
happened even though he saw that it
probably would lead to a disaster can
you say something all right the fact
that the decision-making with
responsibility was shared between
civilian and the military is hard hard
to sort of imagine because people just
take you for granted that the military's
took over but it was not the case
because the leaders actually met over 70
70 times in the one year run up to the
Pacific War and discussed there are
alternatives and different steps to be
taken and they those conferences were
called liaison conferences and that was
not for anything that was called that
because it was its function was to be a
civilian and military strategies and
policies and create a sort of a unified
voice so civilian politicians can't
really say or they didn't really have
any say because they did have in kossei
in those conferences so why did they go
along with it even though they had great
misgivings I think it happened over a
course of period which they gradually
divided themselves into thinking that oh
we can say this much but then some kind
of diplomatic breakthrough will happen
and will so to nullify all the
militaristic steps that they were taking
and when all this deliberation is going
on I think the military leaders had to
put up a really bold front so that to to
preserve their faith and to appease
younger officers who are strategizing
and thinking always about expanding
their sphere of influence and there was
also an inter service like
rivalry the Navy and the army were
always fighting with each other for
bigger budgets and I think in a navy an
army within themselves are very much
divided into different cliques and
sympathies so you can't really talk
about the military voice as one and
monolithic so that's another mister and
how rather makes mincemeat of another
myth which is that there's always
tremendous consensus because on the one
hand on the surface there is consensus
would actually behind the scenes there
was tremendous rivalry and differences
different factions including power log
inning and so on yes and what I was
trying to think of it escapes me know
there's a Japanese expression for the
top guys being driven by the middle
ranking people who are more radical gay
kokuzo yes that's you could explain I
think the exact translation would be
something like the retainers opting the
load the bet does that make sense and he
doesn't sound yes Kay and a translation
the relatively the Lord who has complete
authority in principle but is actually
weak and it's sort of driven into a more
radical position by hot eggs who were in
the middle right it sort of justifies
our sting of power as well by in dying
weak-kneed leaders as ineffective
basically so I think the younger
officers throughout the thirties
especially in the beginning of the this
first half of 1930s up to February coup
in 1936 I think they were really driven
by this desire to to renovate the
Japanese polity and also to strengthen
the imperial system and so on and
everything was done in the name of
salvaging the emperor from corrupt
Western influences that put Japan under
tremendous economic strain and
you know economic considerations cannot
be separated in this period like any
other part of the world so I think they
were hot-blooded
officers and soldiers who were ready to
mobilize or so it was perceived by the
leaders who had to be appeased so they
were in constant state of fear about
what could happen to them as well if
there is also again rather destroys
another myth of Japan as a sort of very
authoritarianism truth in the other hand
the authorities were often not really in
control and you mentioned the 1936 coup
which may not be immediately clear to
everybody in 1936 a number of middle
ranking officers often from the
Northeast
they were country boys and the Northeast
was particularly badly hit by the
depression and that's where people were
often really hungry and the daughters
had to be safe sold into prostitution
and that kind of thing and the military
offices at the time and they weren't of
course unique in this in the world and
believed that the people responsible for
this plight we're the capitalists the
bankers the elite the establishment and
so on and they wanted to there were
radicals of the right and wanted to
stage a coup to put the Emperor to make
the Emperor into a kind of dictator
which he wasn't and to sort of set up a
fascist state there with the emperor in
the center and even though a lot of the
people the Admirals the generals and so
on most rather sympathetic to the aims
of these young hotheads and modest that
their quote unquote sincerity and so on
for the more conservative members of the
establishment including the Imperial
Household I would thought they went too
far they were they didn't disagree with
the aims necessarily but didn't like the
means and so this was a clear case of
young people in the middle ranks driving
the people in authority
in two positions they may not have
wanted to be right I think the fact that
the emperor is so affected by the
experience of the failed crew which
nearly toppled him is important to you
because that affected his passiveness
and perhaps diffidence in putting his
foot down in 1941 and he talks about it
after the war that he thought that if he
tried to veto the more decision he might
be well Japan would have a coup d'etat
of the kind of they try in 1936 hands I
didn't say anything but that also speaks
for the fact that he thought that Bureau
was possible which is in the
Constitution as clear as he claims he
displayed the idea what if they could
have made a case that he was badly
advised and they would have replaced him
with his one of the brothers one of the
problems who was younger mostly much
more radical
yes popular I mean here is an army of
officers well what about the other myth
which is the sort of the Japanese the
myth that the Japanese people including
the Emperor were duped by the militaries
is what is the sort of the standard
mainstream myth the right-wing
nationalist myth which he's still here
in Japan is that Japan was trapped into
it was sort of forced into attacking
Pearl Harbor because they were
surrounded by Western colonial powers
the ABCD the my countrymen were involved
in this America Britain China China and
the Netherlands and that Japan had a
perfect right to defend its interests in
East Asia and that included its presence
in China and and so on and that they
were surrounded by Western powers who
didn't want Japan to have its moment in
the Sun and so they were driven by boy
economic boycotts and that kind of thing
they have no more choice they had
do it and then of course you can also
talk about that the Americans kind of
this is the myth again the Americans
force their hand by the famous hall note
right the ABCD encirclement is a sort of
classic explanation for many of the war
origins no I think I remember World War
one they complained about encirclement
very much and I think that was very much
in on the Japanese mind as well the fact
that the wartime government made use of
that narrative told you in fact gave a
speech on the day of the Pearl Harbor
attack that Japan was reluctantly
question general Tojo who is a prime
minister Minister Japan entered or
reluctantly despite all the nations past
efforts at trying to achieve peace in
East Asia it went hand in hand with this
larger regional agent piece the concept
that Japanese were taken by but sort of
in the end and in effect abused but it
was quite useful at the time as well and
useful to make them believe themselves
that they were fighting for the right
close to so I think that merited was
quite strong and who would really want
to die for the wrong code so you want to
believe that and if your ordinary
citizens without much access to real
information but the China wall or about
Japanese Imperialism I don't think it's
hard to imagine how appealing that
narrative might have been it had a
kernel of truth - of course I mean it's
true that unlike Nazi Germany Japan was
fighting a war against other imperial
powers and George Kennan was one person
who actually criticized the US diplomacy
in retrospect and said that they should
have recognized Japanese interests more
than they did and you could fit the
whole problem really stemmed from the
fact that since the middle middle of the
nineteenth century
when Japan was rather forcefully opened
up by American gunships the Japanese saw
as their only chance to survive as an
independent nation and not be colonized
to be as much like Western powers as
they could and that meant having their
own empire but it was a little late in
the game and but there you cannot one
can sort of understand why it was felt
that they had their right to an empire
just as the Europeans had empires I can
understand the understandable but then
it's not an excuse either the fact that
they had a relative theory a period of
relative peace and democratic experiment
in the 1920s and this wholehearted sort
of attraction to liberal
internationalism of the League of
Nations which Japanese more than anybody
else took seriously I think it's a shame
that he had to go down that way and of
course in the in understanding the
broader frame of mind it's useful to
look at racism colonialism imperialism
and so it's awful but those are not
triggering cause of war or not even in
our medium-term causes of war the causes
for the war had more to do with Japanese
ambitions in East Asia rivalries for the
control of China with the you know
competing against the United States and
Russians as well and the idea that the
fact that they had been quite lucky in
their past Wars probably affected the
military's mindset that perhaps this
reckless war too could be somehow could
be won the past was of course had been
applauded by some of the Western powers
with Teddy Roosevelt
when the Japanese beat the Russians in
the Russell Japanese war of 1905 talked
about the plucky Japanese and
and so did the British and the attack on
the Russian fleet in Port Arthur could
be seen as a kind of not a dress
rehearsal because it was the real thing
but it was a kind of Pearl Harbor at
that time and it succeeded admirably
develop Americans being attacked the
Americas other than the Russians
oh the fact that it is the Operation
Barbarossa was a surprise attack as well
but Russians or the Soviets don't seem
to make as much of a myth about that the
surprise of sneek nature stealth nature
of the attack I think it has to do with
the fact that was so dramatic and in the
fact that the America was attacked on
its soil even though it was a very
heavily Japanese populated island
ironically I think it just became part
of the American psyche and collective
historical narrative and became a symbol
and sort of departed from its real
significance
perhaps over quarters and does that play
into American myths Joel dauer amongst
others and he didn't necessarily condone
the attack on Pearl Harbor in fact he
certainly didn't but he his analysis is
that one of the reasons that the
Americans were so shocked by this event
and so outraged the idea of infamy and
so on was that it it played into the you
see it in so many western movies of the
treacherous Indians who are always
attacking from without warning from
nowhere the brave pioneers and then
suddenly these Redskins screeching war
cries and I think his in his analysis I
think it was a war without mercy I can
remember was that that's one that
explain it's one explanation why the
American why it's still such a strong
myth in America that it
it's exactly that it's this treacherous
attack was it mentally treacherous or
was it was it a screw-up there's a huge
debate about who is responsible the
delay in communicating the determination
of diplomacy to the White House and so
on but the fact that the delayed
document didn't really specify that they
were you know it was not the declaration
of war really so you can't really argue
the stealth of the the attack will have
remained and the sort of treacherous
nature would have not been affected
anyway in Roosevelt's mind the fact that
he had this rhetorical genius and could
mobilize the nation of course it
something do with the enormity of that
legacy but I think there's something to
be said about about the the comparison
to Indians of the Native American
question movies you know not the world
were queens at our breakfast area it's
the sort of verb it just speaks for the
disproportionate asymmetrical nature of
the warfare that was being fought and
that's why I think after 9/11 was so
compelling and so tempting for people to
use that analogy the video the attack
being much like Pearl Harbor and that it
is very under-resourced power could
overtake a giant however momentarily so
I think that another I mean to perhaps
to carry on slightly from what we were
talking about before another analysis by
is it hayashi for Sal who the japanese
intellectual was no longer with us who
started as a communist i think and ended
up as a sort of ultra national right
wing nationalists but he had the
his phrase was the hundred year war in
that pill harbor was part of a war that
actually started in the 1860s when Japan
was opened up by Commodore Perry and
with his gun ships and that ever since
even though there were periods of peace
and truth and so on but ever since Japan
has had been fighting back against
Western dominance is there some truth to
that yes if you look at the whole
history in terms of cultural
civilizational clash but that is just
very tempting and so facile
to explain all the political events that
took place in the mean time and reduce
everything to these worldviews almost of
course these things affect one's
thinking and they act as furniture of
mind but you can't really say Japan went
to war because of the racism of course
you can describe individual beliefs and
how people might have reacted to a
certain situation differently or you
know certain leaders might have held on
to certain beliefs more strongly than
others but just doesn't explain the
whole picture sufficiently in my eyes
but I can see how it could be tempting
and it could fill little books well my
role here be the right-wing Japanese
national Japanese so why did they do it
what did they think they were going to
what was the hope because the even the
great the mastermind of the attack on
Pearl Harbor General of Admiral Yamamoto
who had been at Harvard who's been in
the US Embassy in Washington you need in
the Japanese Japanese Embassy in
Washington who knew the West very well a
very sophisticated man
warned the government I think on several
occasions that it was very reckless
thing to do but he did it nonetheless
now I know that he was a gambling man
and he was probably vain enough to think
that he was the man to do it if any one
but why what did they hope to get out of
it I think in the end it was a gamble
but then by the time that they felt that
they had been cornered into the
situation they justified it in terms of
the slim possibility that something
diplomatic could be worked out after
inflicting a great deal of damage on the
Pacific Fleet on the United States that
even though the war was being declared
in the name of the failure of diplomacy
they expected American side to approach
Japan with diplomatic solution so Japan
itself didn't have any any exit plan
sure Oh jokin right right the fact I
wrote a russo-japanese war with
everything Japan also didn't have an
exit plan there neither and it was
because of Theodore Roosevelt
intervention and peacemaking efforts
that Japan just got away winning it it
was not a straightforward
no no Roosevelt the Japanese almost went
bankrupt into Russell Japanese war it
were bailed out by a banker in New York
Jacob Schiff who had escaped the pogroms
near the anti-semitic pogroms in Russia
so it was not a friend of the Russians
and white Russian officers who were then
arrested were taken prisoner by the
Japanese introduced the Japanese to the
protocols of the Elders of Zion and many
Japanese then put two and two together
to Jacob Schiff bankers perfect we have
to keep the Jews on our side was the
conclusion which is why the Japanese
during World War two refused to hand
over the
and the Nazis when the Germans requested
it from Shanghai and again losing but I
think we're getting close to question
time but the last question perhaps and I
think I'm right and think in saying that
in America Pearl Harbor has become a
sort of mythical occasion which is used
over and over not least after 9/11 and
so but in Japan when people think of
World War two
Pearl Harbor is not the first thing that
comes to mind no I think atomic bombings
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki be the first
things that come to mind but also you
know bombings of every major city I mean
which tends to get forgotten or not
discussed in their congressional I think
that sort of experience died hard but
then it's been almost you know 70 years
nearly 70 years since the end of the war
and that sort of collective experiences
becoming thinner and thinner so I can't
really say even that you they have this
strong attachment to any of the bombings
including a bombings aside for the fact
that they get taught in school much more
effectively than they are being taught
about Japan yeah but there may be
another reason which is we haven't
really discussed that is why so many
Japanese intellectuals often people who
are not fascists or militarists
applauded the attack on Pearl Harbor in
December 1941 partly because it came as
an enormous relief they've been fighting
China even though the official
propaganda was that Japan was liberating
Asia and so on they'd been fighting
China and getting deeper and deeper into
what we can known as the sort of
quagmire people felt rather shame many
people felt embarrassed I think about it
and even now when it's probably true to
said it more people know if they think
about world war 2 at all in Japan know
more about the atrocities committed
against the Chinese and they know about
Pearl Harbor and so a lot of
intellectuals in 1941 felt well at last
we're getting the Western bloody nose at
last were fighting a proper enemy misses
with the war we should have been
fighting to begin with and not our
fellow agents ironically quite a few of
them had studied in the West and sort of
had first-hand experience in in Western
matter so that's why they're ingrained
sources inferiority complexes were much
deeper than others but there's arose the
worst nationalists yes Angele people who
I know this is an argument against
scholarships to people to study abroad
in fact it's a bit like what's his name
Daniel Ortega picked up his
anti-american rhetoric in Berkeley
California but I think it's six o'clock
so perhaps we could open it up to
questions and I'll feel the questions
shall I do it well actually I look
because if you inspect for your mind we
have microphones set up on either side
so I would just ask when I call on you
that you proceed to the microphone and
please identify yourself and you can
address either area or in with your
question so we start with this gentleman
over here could you come to microphone
thank you
hi I'm Noah Smith from Stony Brook
University and the worst dressed person
in the room and um but so I actually add
a couple questions but one of my
questions is one one thing you guys
didn't discuss is that in 1939 Japan
tried attacking a Soviet Union and it
was a lot bigger of an operation than
most people realize and they were
soundly defeated I mean the Soviets sent
in Zhukov and a bunch of Tanks and
basically just creamed them and did news
of that not get out I mean I know that
that experience deeply shook a lot of
the rightest people like Sugie Masanobu
was really freaked out by that and so
didn't that sort of give them pause that
all hushed up and nobody really knew
what had happened
it was hushed up in the public I mean
the newspaper student reported in full
details but the army leadership was of
course shaken and that's why they
decided they couldn't really fight the
Soviet Union and the chance of rose
after June 22nd 1941 and that was very
much on their mind we can't really
afford to to fight the Soviet Union we
have this neutrality pact that Masuka
reached in the spring so we'll just keep
things quiet and keep fighting China and
go into England Indochina French
Indochina too so that they can sustain
that warring position in China for the
time being so like let's attack another
giant it was also part of the into the
inter-services rivalry I think between
the Navy and the army wasn't it that did
the other so-called strike north faction
which was largely army we wanted to go
for the Soviet Union the strike South
faction which was naval because they
needed the resources to keep going who
wanted to fight the war in Southeast
Asia and the debacle in Norman hum in
Mongolia where these battles were fought
against Zhukov the debacle basically
meant the end of the strike north
faction
right and can I get a second question or
am i limited we have other people we can
come back to you listen to Andy
interesting okay I've hijacked the mine
um so so I'm also kind of interested in
Tojo Hideki was to what extent was he
sort of trying to to ride herd on these
factions and and sort of move Japan
toward being a more centralized less
factionist system at what point so I
mean what little I've read about him
kind of indicated that he that he was
sort of trying to be more I mean Japan
was it's very factionalized plays
without much of a chain of command you
know and so to what extent was he trying
to change that we see a centralizing he
went and he he was into efficiency
because he was an able bureaucrat if
anything sorry able bureaucrat able not
never regret variable bureaucrat who
kept you know individual notes about you
know people that he dealt with every day
of his life and you know they held
grudge against certain people who
punished them and so and so forth but I
think he did he did try to centralize
and also I think his primary motive was
to help the Emperor because he was a
very devoted servant of the imperial
institution so when he was appointed
prime minister in October mid October
1941 the first thing he tried to do was
to avert to all try to discuss
alternative scenarios which really goes
against this idea of told you're being
very openly bellicose and you know
uncompromising about going to all which
is not true so he was a bit more complex
simple-minded and he was I think his
position was bit more complex Thank You
Jeffrey
Jeff Laurenti Ian had mentioned the
China quagmire at the very end of your
dialogue and I wonder if you could
explore for us a bit to what extent in
1941 was China and the China quagmire
itself perhaps the main driver of
Japanese war and diplomatic policy that
is was the attack on the US in a sense
if you have a problem you can't solve
make it bigger and then maybe you'll be
able to find new opportunities and to
what extent were they talking about some
kind of either peace feelers or some
kind of accommodation or was that
entirely off the table for China
what were their war aims in China at
that point and if you could make an even
larger picture to what extent where it
sparked in Japan's partners in the
tripartite pact and their actions in
Europe like the invasions of a union if
anything an inducement to we can do more
we can think more boldly look the
Germans are at the gates of Moscow to
what accept were they looking to their
axis partners in Europe as a model and a
further incitement to thinking big thank
you
I think the China were was central and
they did discuss that it was essential
for them to end the China or somehow to
end it meant to exit honorable Asian
Richard Nixon's it goes to well well
maybe come up with the peace terms that
were favorable they had set up this
puppet regime of lunging way in Nanjing
where the Japanese occupied and they
wanted the Americans to recognize that
regime as well and have two nationalist
regimes basically in China which didn't
make sense for the Americas Americans
had no inkling to recognize the regime
in the first place but in the
negotiations that took place in
Washington between the Japanese
ambassador Nomura and coral Holland
Roosevelt since April 1941 China was
always there China
she was always engaged on conferences in
Tokyo was always discussed and it became
really the sticking point of the
negotiation that they couldn't the
military especially the army couldn't
openly say that we are willing to
withdraw if in the u.s. you know you
lifted sanctions or you know some kind
of bargaining could might have been you
know struck that they couldn't really
openly discuss these things so they were
the militaries in Japan were depending
on civilian leaders like Conaway to
reach a diplomatic breakthrough pond I
thought that he could prefer diplomatic
resolution if he met Roosevelt in person
so he promised too much at home to the
military you can prepare for war in the
meantime because you never know but you
have to allow me to go see Roosevelt in
say Hawaii or Alaska and he thought and
the military thought that that was going
to happen until quite late until
September mid-september
even early October and when they sort of
noticed that Americans are not going to
come to the negotiating table that's a
you know Paula I panicked in
so China web central and they knew it
your second question is about tripartite
packet how they I think they were
mesmerized by the German successes not
that they understood the dangerous sort
of lethal aspects with Nazi ideology or
heartedly embraced it because Japanese
were relegated to second-class citizens
the yellow race was not really honorably
themself wanted to be there but people
who read the tract in the original
German did know the truth of Hitler's
pronouncement so that was not so much
the sort of embracing of the ideology
but the sort of a marshal aspect of the
Nazi success and also the fact that the
shock factors in Europe especially after
Barbarossa that people were just
Japanese
casually thought okay Southeast Asia is
really right for plucking because
nobody's looking at it and if we could
push the Vichy regime to hand it over
peaceably with the threat of force you
know the Western powers are not gonna
quibble because it's so far away big
mistake I think that was that that's
what triggered the total embargo on oil
or de facto total embargo on petroleum
and freezing of Japanese assets by
Allied powers just to add to that I
think that didn't they also see
Operation Barbarossa as an opportunity
to attack northerly Southeast Asia but
even the United States because they
thought that with the Russians out of
the way Europe would go with the hardest
called the military strategists in the
general stuff big toy with that idea
that was not the mainstream because they
were not thinking in terms of war at
that point in July 1940
at all they they were more concerned
about power struggle at home Matsuoka
Yosuke the eccentric foreign minister
who's becoming a person a non grata with
in the corner cabinet had to be
undermined and he was saying oh you know
just show the gesture to the ally you
know Germany ally Germany and attack
Soviet Union just quickly so that we can
you know claim to have participated in
their war and you know maybe take some
Soviet positions but everyone including
the Army who had traditionally seen in
the Soviet Union as the hypothetical
enemy opposed to you know posted you
know it was partly because the
experience of Nam on hand that really
you know told them otherwise it was also
to undermine the position that Matsuoka
was taking and kono especially wanted
him to to leave his cabinet without him
having to do to his own hands but the
relations with the axis power was a very
old one because they didn't really trust
one another and and the question whether
the issue had wanted dead the Jews on
their side is one illustration of this
but on the other hand you hear stories
from German businessmen who visited
Japan until not very long ago and being
taken out for a drunken evening on the
Ginza by their Japanese colleagues then
thought it would please their West
German colleagues enormously if they
over there Stein's of beer would
suddenly start seeing the horse vessel
lead which was not the thing to do to
ingratiate themselves with most Western
the business and maybe some no they
wouldn't have admitted it
George Burrell Steen I'm afraid part of
the question has been taken up I was
interested in the weather
Germany was instrumental in urging Japan
to enter the war and I was curious did
they know that the Japanese were going
to attack or any of the details of it
after the attack America declared war
but not against Germany and there was a
period of five days or so when it wasn't
clear what was going to happen and there
was even some thought that it might be
beneficial for Hitler to not declare war
and see what happened if that didn't
happen but I do know the details of
those few days and what the did the
Germans urged Japan to do this not as
far as I know and I doubt if they they
knew and that's all and one of the
mysteries of World War two is why Hitler
and decided to declare war in the United
States which he didn't actually have to
do but maybe hit there was an honorable
man but and thank goodness he did
because that made it very easy for a
Roosevelt to get into the European war
and so it's not for nothing that when
Churchill was given the news over a I
think a late-night dinner at checkers or
wherever he was and he said it was the
first night no it wasn't the first night
he slept very well but he slept very
well to add to that I think that what
Germans were schemed for the Japanese to
do in the middle of 1941 was to attack
Singapore for Japan to attack Singapore
so that they could help the locals in in
the Soviet Union somehow and you know
bring the rope Hitler was obsessed with
this idea of of course conquering the
Isle of Britain so I think he probably
thought the Japanese could be used that
way more effectively by way of attacking
it was actually very little
communication wasn't there during the
war between the axis axis partners and
Don Simmons is my name a different topic
for several decades after the Second
World War both Germany and Japan did all
they could to sort of reintroduce
themselves reintegrate themselves with
the rest of the world subdued military
policy particularly case of Japan and
generally trying to be could create to
contribute as much of the common good as
I could in a case with Germany within 20
or 25 years their relations with their
neighbors and including very much
occupied countries were ranged somewhere
from cordial to warm that did not happen
with Japan and still has not happened
and I I guess what why the difference is
the boat stays on but you've written a
book about that
so maybe books on there well there is a
very long answer to that in a short
tissue and one is that there were very
different neighbors Germany was in the
middle of Europe and its neighbors to
the west where Western democracies and
who were tied to West Germany in a
military alliance as well as in unifying
Europe and that was a very different
proposition to being surrounded the
Japan's immediate neighbors were
Communist China and then South Korea
which was as kind of a lie and then you
had North Korea so they didn't and there
wasn't an East Asian alliance that is in
any way comparable to the European
community or NATO that's one reason I
think the other reason is and although
and also I think one mustn't overstate
the warmth of the relations between
Germany and its immediate neighbors
certainly in I remember in 1974 719 1988
when my own country the Netherlands beat
Germany at the European soccer
championship more people went into the
streets to celebrate
in May 5 1945 at the end of the war but
having said that there were very
different Wars I mean when people and
there were two Germany's that's the
other thing there was West Germany and
East Germany and they had very different
relations with the outside world as far
as West Germany is concerned when people
talk about coming to terms with the past
and all that kind of thing people really
are not talking about the invasion of
Norway they're talking about the
Holocaust and that's a very specific
crime committed by a criminal regime
Japan didn't really have a criminal
regime they were the same people who are
in power who've been in power before the
war and there wasn't an equivalent to
the Holocaust in the sense of an
ideological ideological war to
exterminate a particular people because
they didn't have the right to exist so
for all these reasons I think relations
with the outside world I mean there are
other reasons to do with the pacifist
Constitution and the fact that the
wartime history became very political
issue in Japan and they're polarized one
unlike the history of the Third Reich in
Germany which is not a particularly
polarizing issue so I think there are a
large number of reasons none of them
have much to do with some kind of
essential aspect of the Japanese
character or anything of that sense that
kind I hope that answered something
harry did you share something to matter
so I agree with another right over you I
had a very soft way Julian td5 sorry
Matthew Olsen I had a very soft question
but you have raised a very hard question
I'll start with a hard question I have
read about islands in especially in the
neighborhood of Indonesia where entire
populations were wiped out I've never
forgotten my reading of a rape avenging
and so when you talk about the
difference between what the Nazis were
doing and I understand it was pretty
lost and what the Japanese were doing
I'm not clear that there's a difference
because they were both wiping out
populations hard question second
question just if you can starting with
grade school when I first started his
reading history they talked about the
warm relations between the United States
after the opening of Japan and that warm
relation was supposed to have taken
player continued until the start of the
Japanese Russo peace brokered by
Roosevelt and the explanation that I was
given and I've ever read a contradiction
of this sense was that that was the
beginning at the end of the Japanese us
friendship because Japanese resented the
fact that they didn't get more out of
the peace than they thought they should
have gotten and they thought the United
States cheated us and I'm perfectly open
to that hypothesis being questioned or
denied but this is my first opportunity
to add somebody knowledgeable in a
subject thank you
you listed 100 okay that I had not heard
that narrative before because I think in
Japan they concentrate on the failure of
diplomats or the negotiators who didn't
get Russian indemnities in the terms of
peace and there was a riot afterwards
and so it's over so it was more
perceived in Japan as a failure of
diplomacy which sort of explains the the
popularity of very strong hard-nosed
diplomats like battlecry Oska who who
signed the tripartite pact that you know
here was this very clear-headed diplomat
who could stand up for Japanese
interests
he was incidentally the one who walked
the delegation out of League of Nations
after the most Manchurian crisis erupted
so I think it's more perceived the
russo-japanese war and settlements is
perceived in terms of the failure of
Japanese diplomacy more than sort of
American design so it's not I've never
heard it blamed on the American side if
anything is sort of perpetuated the idea
that America great power could afford to
to be generous and it'll be a peace
broker that sort of thing so that when
the China was not really going anywhere
from the Japanese perspective new
Japanese kept asking Americans to be the
mediator between Chiang kai-shek and the
Japanese so I think that sort of built
in the sixth you know perhaps out there
expectations
Japanese expectations of the United
States as being some kind of benevolent
policeman standing up for Japanese
interest rather than anything else which
is self-serving scores
yeah on the atrocities of course it
makes very little difference if you're
the victim of somebody torturing you or
let alone shooting you it doesn't really
make much difference who's doing it or
for what reasons but I think there is a
difference between military atrocities
and they were indeed terrible not just
in Nanjing in China but in Manila and
other places and which cannot be excused
they should be faced there they're
horrifying but there is a slight
difference between military atrocities
and we can go in we can talk about why
they happened and a government that has
a program to exterminate people for
ideological reasons because they do not
have the right to exist and there was
never such a thing in the Japanese war
in the Japanese war there are many
military atrocities and if you like if
one is going to be provocative about it
they were the psychology of Nanjing is a
bit like what happened in malai during
the Vietnam War but in a vast scale in
that you had a lot of soldiers in
hostile territory who often couldn't see
the difference between civilians and
guerrilla fighters and so on they were
undisciplined brutalized by their own
offices and we're often found themselves
into a position that they thought were
the safest thing to do is just to shoot
everybody and that can quickly escalate
to sort of orgies of violence and again
what we were talking about earlier where
the senior officers are not really in
proper control of the middle-ranking
ones I think played a role as well that
there was even though the image of the
Japanese army entirely correct when it
came to the russo-japanese war when they
were very disciplined and actually
treated POWs very well and so on
that the discipline often left a lot to
be desired in the Second World War and
so you did have these enormous massacres
and
raping and looting on a vast scale and
so on but it's not quite the same thing
of it to be a tea to be a victim of this
is equally unpleasant but it's not quite
the same thing as gassing people or
shooting people because they don't have
the right to live could you come down
here free thank you
hi I'm Richard Katz um I'm sort of
fascinated by the degree of
misperception in both Tokyo and
Washington of the other and I've had
conversations and people actually who
are descendants of somewhat of Japanese
leaders at the time who thought that
they really believed that the United
States for the service or their proposal
be the plan B for peace or at least that
the US would actually accept the
document that ratified Japanese control
over China which of course the u.s. did
not do and the fact that they really
thought the US might do this is an
incredible my mind misperception of of
everything into a studying degree and
then from the American side from what I
can see there were two groups in the
leadership both of the word kind of nuts
about what they thought about Japan and
they're very well informed people on the
one hand you have say Stanley Horne back
in the State Department who knows Japan
very well who insisted that Japan would
never go to war against the United
States because they knew they're going
to get smashed when some diplomats in
the embassy said well they out of sheer
desperation they might do it he goes
when is the nation ever attack out of
sheer desperation so he was said let's
take a very hard line because I will
force the Japanese to back down they
won't dare attack us and then you have
Joseph GRU who again very very informed
ambassador for god knows how long in
Japan who kept talking about these
mythological moderates and peaceniks
in Tokyo that we dare not undermine by
being too soft their book should we take
a very soft line so the moderates can
come to the fore and it seems to me that
besides all the issues of a tryst and
clashes whatever but the astonishing
degree of of misperception by at least
in the American side people who should
have been better who are these reformed
I don't know the level of in frontier
information Japanese side but if you can
discuss what's the self delusion or what
was going on that created this
incredible degree of what I see is just
people lying to themselves about about
about the other side you're talking
about Japan not Iran
well you see that's the second question
I was feeling I like to think about
China tell you through but anyway I
think the u.s. perception of Japan has
we could be described as underestimation
of the resolve or desperation or
whatever but then I think Japanese
himself didn't really most leaders
didn't couldn't have conceived of this
plan of attack had it not been for
Yamamoto Isoroku so I think it was quite
an outlandish thing to do and to pull
off anyway I think Roosevelt was perhaps
expecting some minor attack even as late
as to the December 1st my notic on the
Philippines or Thailand or wherever
because he saw the troops mobilizing
around Taiwan and he couldn't have
perceived of this attack on Pearl Harbor
which really was a dramatic turn of
event so I don't think in the Japanese
themselves were surprised by that too so
I think there was an underestimation of
what Yamamoto could do in both in all
sides almost that's my feeling about it
and I think then military leaders
someone like maybe General Staff
Nagano Sammy when he looked at the plans
in late October he said no way we are
not going to do it it's too risky
we are not gonna win this war anyway so
why in your white risk so much you know
we'll lose all our battleships
it's hard to over to underestimate the
human capacity for self-delusion I mean
that for example there's a wonderful
film made in Japan in 1942 and it came
out in December 1942 and was
commissioned by the Imperial Japanese
Navy to celebrate Pearl Harbor and they
recreated the attack so well with it was
one of the first films that use special
effects so skillfully that they're still
sometimes used in documentaries about
the Hubble because there
little actual documentary footage of it
and one of the scenes shows the the
pilots and so on on the aircraft carries
on their way to Pearl Harbor and they
listen in to the American radio on
Hawaii and they hear jazz music and
somebody conducting a dance and they all
giggle and say well this is the
Americans and the decadent weak-kneed
Americans all they can do is dance and
listen to this this absurd sort of music
and I mean if they once they get a taste
of the real Japanese martial spirit
they'll cave in and it's a very common
misperception of Democracies held not
just by the Japanese at the time but by
authoritarian regimes and then there
were more idiotic misperceptions too on
both sides I think on the Japanese side
some people really believe that
Americans couldn't shoot straight
because their nose is we're too big so
they couldn't look past their noses at
the same time in America there were
ideas of the Japanese because of them
they're oriental Mongol eyes couldn't
shoot straight because and so on so the
stupidity of people is usually boundless
well I am sure Japan 1941 was maybe not
the topic of your breakfast conversation
but you'll probably talk a lot about it
at dinner so and I want to thank you
both for being with us
[Music]
[Applause]
you're watching both